[Music]
in churches up and down the land come
May the 6th Bells will ring for the King
on Coronation Day at least that's the
plan problem is there simply Aren't
Enough Bell ringers to go around
[Music]
the race is on to find more recruits
like nine-year-old Flo Riley who's being
trained up at Saint Lawrence's Church
near Seven Oaks in Kent well it feels
nice because people from miles around
can hear you ring the bells in this
church
nearby it's sir nicholases the bells are
usually silenced during practice for the
sake of the neighbors among the new bell
ringers is ten-year-old Lexi Roberts she
can't wait to be part of history on
coronation day it'll be amazing because
I can brag to my siblings about it there
are 38 000 Bells across the UK but when
the recruitment Drive began in October
there were only thirty thousand ringers
it's a great opportunity with the king's
coronation for people to come together
to Ring to learn to ring it's an
incentive for them to want to do
something for something really really
special that may be the only opportunity
in their lifetime who knows so far 1500
potential recruits have come forward to
fill 8 000 vacancies but time is running
out
now you might think it's simply a matter
of pulling a rope at the right moment
turns out there's more to it than that
apparently it takes 15 to 20 hours to
learn how to handle a bell properly and
that's before you even think about
joining a group
[Music]
there are rehearsals happening all over
the country at St olavs in the city of
London another group of bell ringers or
campanologists as they're known were
practicing on Saturday and we're going
to be bringing a court appeal which
takes about 45 minutes or an hour it's a
recorded performance
but there's going to be lots more
recorded performance coming up in the
next sort of couple of months so people
all over the country will be reading
Court appeals and pills which might take
up to three hours three and a half hours
something like that
then weeks to go until the
the big time is ticking for those still
learning the ropes
Emma birchley's Sky News Kent